hey everyone welcome back and in this
video i'm gonna go ahead and discuss
about a very interesting feature in
react which is only available in react
18 and above also if you're new here
make sure you like and subscribe to the
channel i'll be creating a lot of
content on javascript full stack web
development react and a lot of similar
topics so if you want to keep yourself
updated to this stuff make sure you
subscribe and hit the bell icon and
we're going to be taking a look at
concurrent ui again in react i did a
video on this i think a couple of years
ago when concurrent mode was first
announced but since then concurrent mode
has been a little delayed in terms of
when it would come out but when it will
come out finally it will be awesome and
in react 18 you can pretty much opt in
into concurrent modes a few few of the
features now
not actually going exactly into
concurrent mode how it really works and
so on and so forth but what we'll be
taking a look at is something known as
create root in react which is different
and which is what you have to use in
order to opt into concrete mode so what
i want to do here is actually go ahead
and inside the code down playground i
want to open
the index.jsx file and i will just
remove the strict mode for now so
the moment we do that
what's gonna happen
is you're gonna see that we have this
line called react dom dot render then
the component and where it should be
rendered on the screen and this is
pretty standard stuff we have discussed
this in our react course and full stack
learning path as well but what has
changed in react 18 and i'm running
react 18 in this one it's an alpha
preview but i'm still running or react
18. what react 18 brings us is that it
brings us support of this create root
and what this is like the comment says
is that it allows you to opt into
concurrent mode so we'll discuss what
concurrent mode really is once it is a
little bit more stable and out in the
wild but for now let's just opt into
this new rendering feature of react so
what you need to do is you can just say
what is my root element in this case
it's
document.getelementbyid with root and
then what you have to do is say react
we
dom dot create root and then pass in the
root element and you can say this is my
react root
for example something like this and you
can see right here
once you do that you can call a dot
render on this so let's take a look at
what this render how this render we have
to use in the code dam example and all i
have to do
is
say react root dot render and then
this thing
right here
right
this could be pretty much any element
right and like it says that you can also
nest them together here as well so
what this does is that it allows us to
use
these features which you will be able to
see in the concurrent mode table let me
just see if i can find that table so
yeah this is the table which shows you
the legacy mode the blocking mode and
the concurrent mode so legacy mode is
the thing which is available right now
right in react pretty much so you know
that we could reuse suspense and react
why because although it's a concurrent
mode feature but it still is available
in the legacy mode the blocking mode
we'll probably not talk a lot about here
because blocking mode is for those code
bases who have
some custom
you know implementations of a few things
and which get broken when we shift to
concrete mode so it's like a middle
ground between legacy mode and concrete
mode almost always if you're trying to
create a new project after react 18 you
want to start with concurrent mode right
away right and that's what create root
does so there are two to three modifiers
here you can see the first one is create
blocking root the second one is create
root and the third one is just directly
render on react on so these respectively
just render and you know just start the
react js rendering engine into that
particular mode we'll stick to the
create root mode and what it does is one
of the features you can see right here
which saves us is automatic batching of
multiple set states right which is not
available here i mean it is kind of
we'll see what this means but this is
definitely available in these two and
this is what we will discuss in this
video how create root makes it work not
exactly how because that's an internal
detail but how you can make it work
there are so many other areas which are
very interesting and we should be
exploring in the further videos but this
one i found the easiest and the most
interesting one as well so what we want
to do is we want to take a look at this
example from the official docs itself
and let me just go ahead and minimize
this so i can show you what's exactly
happening so
for the sake of this video i'm just
gonna switch let's say i'm gonna switch
to back to legacy mode for now i'm gonna
say react
dom
dot render
app
inside of root
right so the moment i do this refresh
this page i'm in the legacy mode now pay
close attention to what's happening here
we have a first component component one
we have a component two and we have this
app right and this is the exported
component so you can see component 2
actually calculates how many times it
has been re-rendered right this is this
is just calculating how many times it
has been re-rendered right and this
count will update here every single time
this re-renders um component 1 does the
similar thing the only two difference
the only one difference or two is in
these both of them is that when i click
on this button called next in component
two i do this
update inside of a promised callback
right and this is just a regular promise
which does not has any major
significance but you can see i do this
callback inside of the promise
this update inside of a callback and
inside component one i do this
right inside the function now in the
legacy mode what you would see
is something weird that when i click on
the component one which is this function
when i click on this you can see the
number keeps on incrementing and the
re-renders also increment in the similar
fashion right
why because right here when i click on
this button
although we have two state updates
happening here react batches them
together and just performs a one dom
update right that means this function
re-renders this function is destroyed
and called by react only one time even
though we are sending two state
variables here this is important because
if there was an await call here it would
have been two updates right which also
makes sense because our weight can
pretty much take any arbitrary amount of
time in order to resolve a promise but
here what you see here is that in
component 2 even though these two calls
are happening one after another the fact
they are inside of a promise callback
results in the following code so when i
click on this you can see we get two
re-renders not one then if i click on
this again we get four re-renders not
two
right and so on so you can see that in
case i have a promise and i call a state
update inside of that so anytime you add
more state updates react will actually
tear down this function and reconstruct
it again and again and again on a single
state update this is bad performance
wise because now react is doing multiple
renders where one would have sufficed
right react 18's concurrent mode opting
into content mode fixes this how because
now if i go ahead and remove this and
opt into the create root mode which is
our react concurrent mode now if i go
ahead and use the same code as before
this of course works just like before
but this right here also works like a
buff because now what's happening is
that we are using
this thing right here automatic batching
of multiple set states now the reason it
says that it's a star because you can
see that legacy mode has automatic
batching and react managed events but
it's limited to one browser task
non-react events whatever right this
just means that
you will not be able to have react
bashing these set state calls inside of
promises or instead of callbacks or
anything like that if you're not on
react 18 right so this is just one video
one example of what create root will
bring as uh as a change to the act and
there are interesting things here i mean
if you try to look into suspense and
suspense list suspense list is also
interesting where you can actually
define an order in which the components
appear on the screen
right so we'll discuss that as time goes
on and as more and more features become
stabilized but this is something i think
was pretty interesting and pretty
important and probably something you
should even know about as well right
that if you use multiple calls or
functions like this you don't have to be
afraid of multiple renders reactors
smart enough to just match them all
together and do it in one go so yep
that's pretty much it for this video if
you learned something from this make
sure you leave a like and subscribe to
the channel thank you so much for
watching and i'm gonna see you in the
next one really soon
[Music]
you